i et combrée la ville et le roman le
présent et le passé
et pourtant à mêmes lieux visités par
cinq mille personnes chaque année les
habitants d'illiez les issia rien en ont
vu plus d'un la recherche du temps perdu
sous le bras l'air de vous voir mes
costumes et comme pouvait l'être votre
arrière grand père
bret de loin à dix lieues à la ronde vu
du chemin de fer que nous y arrivions la
dernière semaine avant pâques
ce n'était qu'une église résumant la
ville la représentante en parlant d'elle
est pour elle au lointain et quand on
s'approchait tenant serré autour de sa
hotte menthe sombre en plein champ
contre le vent comme une passe tour ses
brebis le dos les noeuds et gris des
maisons va sembler qu'un reste de
rempart du moyen-âge cerner çà et là
d'un trait aussi parfaitement
circulaires qu'une petite ville dans un
tableau du primitif
de la gare à la place du marché comme du
temps où marcel proust entre 5 et 10 ans
venez passer ses vacances ou la tante
léonie dans la ville natale de son père
le célèbre docteur adrien pouces
mais d'un milieu modeste et proust
devant les des cierges dans cette liste
et l'oncle amour tout ici une épicerie
habité milliers étaient à patricia les
nuits étaient longues
je me plaignais de maladie beaucoup de
jeunes y était chétif le visage de ton
grave et le par l'élan le prêtre était
souvent appelés pour des mourants et les
cloches sonner souvent pour les morts et
pourtant l'enfant délivrer de sa cage
parisienne d'auray et contraignantes
trouver du charme name à la chambre de
la tante léonie atteinte d'un cancer
avec à portée de main tout ce qu'il
fallait poursuivre de son lit les
offices et son régime pour ne manquer
leur nid de la pepsine dit dr françoise
vous seriez venus cinq minutes plus tôt
vous auriez vu passer madame humbert qui
tenait des asperges deux fois grosses
comme celles de la mer cadeau qu'un chez
donc de savoir par sa bonne maîtrise a
eu
et tandis que temps que léonie commente
avec françoise la gouvernante la
chronique quotidienne mais mémorial de
combrée les filles de cuisine prépare
les ingrédients d'une alchimie savante
mystérieuse mais aussi cruelle celle de
l'art culinaire semblable à
l'élaboration d'un roman auquel on goûte
avec délice
dans la salle à manger la chambre où le
jardin le temps cn au fil de la lecture
à laquelle l'enfant signe ici avec
françois le champi
l'enfant fragile
passionnément épris de sa mère parfois
distraits par la lanterne magique mais
inconsolable lorsque retenu par la
visite de monsieur swan elle n'est pas
venue l'embrasser dans sa chambre alors
toutes les rues sont bonnes pour forcer
sa mère à venir calmer son chagrin
l'amant passe à cette nuit là dans ma
chambre au moment je venais de commettre
une faute elle que je m'attendais à être
obligés de quitter la maison mais pas
rom accorder plus que je n'ai jamais
obtenu 2 comme récompense d'une belle
action plutôt bien que mal la maison de
tante léonie se laisse habiter par le
roman ils sont en est pourtant fallu de
peu pour que ce lieu de la mémoire
n'échappe aux lecteurs du proust ne
trouverez plus le petit cabinet sentant
l'iris détruit par de récents travaux de
rénovation voici ce qu'il reste de la
salle de bains comparer à des termes
inspiré du voyage orientale de l'anc
lannion
vous pouvez toujours si le coeur vous en
dit trempez votre madeleine dans la
tasse de thé mais l'effet n'est pas
garanti
et